quebec's interim public health director
dr luke boileau says wearing masks to
protect against coven 19 will become a
personal choice the government's
projected date for lifting the mask
mandate is mid-april but he warns
quebecers might be making their choice
sooner rather than later it could be
earlier
early april end of march even third of
march it will depend on the progression
of the hospitalization for the next
let's say 10 to 15 days the mandate
would not apply to health care settings
and mass transit boiler says since about
3 million quebecers have caught covet in
the past two months it's no longer
feasible to make masks mandatory it's
very difficult to continue to argue to
everyone to wear it because some might
be at risk dr christopher labo says
masks are a safeguard against potential
future waves of the virus there's almost
no downside beyond a mild inconvenience
there's no medical harms they're not
dangerous in any way they cost virtually
nothing and they are very effective at
blocking the transmission of a
respiratory virus so when given the
choice will quebecers continue to wear a
mask we asked pedestrians on st
catherine street in crowded areas i will
an airport something like that for sure
i might keep my mask just in case i have
through my three shots but we never know
it's still you know still around this
clinical psychologist predicts it will
take time to adapt especially after
people have been rigorously following
health measures for the past two years
to change that kind of mentality
overnight is something that is in the
realm of the collusion the government
says it will give 10 days notice before
lifting the mask mandate regardless of
the choice quebecers make fober says it
will be a transition period it's going
to require respect it's going to require
patience it's going to require a lot of
confidence you know and trust olivia
o'malley global news montreal